Weizen rost sein name klingt harmlos doch der schädling versetzt nicht nur die landwirtschaft weltweit
in angst und schrecken
eigentlich galt ja schon längst als besiegt doch eine neue sorte befällt riesige felder und bedroht damit tatsächlich die menschheit
forschungsteams weltweit suchen händeringend nach lösungen
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp gewünscht und jetzt also alle wichtigen facts zum pilz namens
weizen rost welche gefahren gehen wirklich von dieser pflanzen krankheit aus und warum sind wir so macht das alles jetzt in klicks und science fiction
herzlich willkommen
Eigentlich hatte die pflanzenkrankheit
weizen schwarz rost keine rolle mehr in deutschland gespielt der pilz gehört zu den getreide rosten eine gruppe von sharp pilzen die
verschiedene
getreidefeld konkret steckt der pilz bikini
agrarminister hinter der tatsächlich im nur einen gesunden weizen bestand ruinieren kann
früher gab es weltweit immer wieder schwarz rost epidemien die ganze ernten vernichten mit verheerenden folgen ihr könnt euch vorstellen
doch dann wurde in den 50er und 60er jahren wurden neue
resistenzgene in den weizen eingekreuzt und lange hatte man tatsächlich ruhe bis vor 20 jahren denn dann wurde
ug99 entdeckt und zwei agenda deswegen auch der name
für uganda und 99 für das jahr seiner entdeckung konkret
handelt es sich um eine schwarz ross trasse die wirklich angst einflößen ist denn er ist
deutlich virulenter als alle anderen schwarz kosten die man bis zu diesem zeitpunkt kannte also er verbreitet sich schneller
die meisten resistenzen die den weizen seit jahrzehnten geschützt hatten waren ihm egal und seit 1999
hat er sich rasend schnell verbreitet über das östliche afrika bis ägypten in den nahen osten hinein und das innerhalb weniger jahre
2008 waren mehr als 80 prozent aller weizen sorten anfällig für den weizen rost
mittlerweile gibt es einige sorten die resistenz sind dennoch bauern weltweit sind alarmiert und es wäre nicht weniger als eine gigantische
katastrophe wenn
ug99 in china oder indien
dann würde aber auch überall anders auf der welt geht von dem pilz eine große gefahr aus denn neben mais und reis
gehört weizen mit zu den wichtigsten nahrungsmitteln mehr als eine milliarde menschen
ernähren sich davon nicht umsonst hat die food and
agriculture organisation der vereinten nationen eine meldung herausgegeben in der sie die bauern in europa
eindringlich warnt der weizen bestand solle besonders intensiv geprüft werden und falls erste anzeichen
eines schwarz-roten falls auftreten sofort gegenmaßnahmen
einleiten gemeint ist der intensive einsatz von
fungiziden also pilzgiften
2016 zerstörte der erreger den großteil der weizenernte auf sizilien seine sporen sind wohl sicherlich mit dem wind über südeuropa
verteilt worden kraftfahrern strahlung stört die pilzsporen nicht und so legen sie mit globalen luftströmen oft hunderte kilometer
zurück und zwar bis an den rand der atmosphäre
und so sind wir auch in deutschland längst nicht mehr sicher und das
obwohl unser oft nasser und kühler sommer eigentlich nichts für den pilz ist aber das hat sich ja auch in den letzten jahren geändert
2013 tauchte er zunächst im harz auch später dann auch in sachsen-anhalt niedersachsen thüringen sachsen und brandenburg ganze
weizenfelder befallen von schwarzen posten was das bedeutet ist klar ein extremer einsatz von pilzgiften
verheerende ernteeinbußen und je nachdem ein krasser preisanstieg für weizen auf dem weltmarkt
dies würde vor allem für diejenigen die sich teure weizen nicht leisten können eines bedeuten hunger doch warum kommen
forschungsteams mit heutigen techniken kaufen gegen den pilz an
zum einen dachte man bis 1999 dass die krankheit besiegt sei damals gab es nur noch wenige experten für den schwarz rost
mittlerweile haben weltweit unzählige
forschungsteams dem pilz den kampf angesagt eines der erklärten ziele ist es beispielsweise ein europaweiter frühwarnsystem zu installieren
doch der einsatz von fungiziden
ist keine dauerlösung und so wird auch an einer art zucht plein geforscht wird man in der lage immer neue weizensorten zu produzieren die
resistenz sind der zweite grund warum noch immer keine
hundertprozentige strategie gegen den pilz erwacht wurde nicht alle lebensstadien des pilzes sind hinreichend erforscht
wir wissen die pilz rassen sind extrem vielfältig und umso
anpassungsfähiger gegen alle möglichen resistenzgenen so sind sie in der lage immer neue weizensorten zu infizieren ug99
beispielsweise begann mit einer rasse inzwischen ist sie zu einer ganzen pilz familie ausgewachsen doch wie kann das passieren
eine große aber noch nicht vollständig geklärte rolle spielt hierbei wohl die berberitze
die kennt man vielleicht als hecke mit den leuchtend roten beeren und sie ist wohl eine art zwischen wird für den
schwarzweiß denn rolf pilze sind wie viele parasiten dazu in der lage sich auf zwei verschiedene arten zu vermehren
die einfachste möglichkeit die bild zellen teilen sich und produzieren so fast identische klone
genau das passiert im weizen aber rostpilze sind zudem in der lage sich sexuell fortzupflanzen der sex zwischen pilzen
funktioniert wohl sehr wahrscheinlich über die berberitze zwei zellen verschmelzen
mission das erbgut und vermehren sich dann weiter dieses lebens stadium des pilzes wird oft außer acht gelassen
forschungsteams haben jedenfalls die starke vermutung dass die berberitze ein grund für die ungewöhnliche vielfalt
des deutschen schwarz rosses sein könnte schon früh lernte man das schon in den
1920 er jahren wurden die berberitzen büsche
massenhaft vernichtet doch immer noch unklar sind viele fragen die beim kampf gegen den schadpilz eine entscheidende rolle spielen wie
beeinflusst sie die berberitze die evolution neuer pilz lassen sie vermehrt sich der pilz auf ihr und welche rolle spielt sie bei
epidemien er ist wenn man dies weiß könnte endlich eine strategie gegen die pflanzenkrankheit
entwickelt werden die auch uns menschen im hohen maße bedroht wenn ihr kein video verpassen wollte zu diesem und zu anderen themen
und auch extra videos und livestreams nicht dann werdet mitglied hier auf dem kanal und nimmt auch noch ein paar privilegien mit außerdem
unterstützt sie uns mit einem kleinen betrag einfach auf mitglied werden klicken hier unter dem video
und einen riesen dank an die die schon dabei sind das macht uns etwas unabhängiger von den schwankenden werbeeinnahmen hier auf youtube wenn er immer
garantiert über aktuelle videos informiert werden wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp darum geht ihr die etwas
unzuverlässige abo boxee auf youtube und er verpasst kein video einfach hier draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
dafür hier klicken aber nicht nicht die
genau die glocke vergessen hier geht's weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken gefährliche mückenart in deutschland bis dann
bleibt dran